revolution you have followed both those
in 1979 people forget two major things
happen the siege of Mecca the Great
Mosque of Mecca and the fall of the Shah
of Iran and the rise of Khomeini's
government right the Islamic Revolution
this book the complete infidels guide to
run and by the way it's another fabulous
book from Regnery you make I don't know
if it's charges I want to go through
this I mean you're basically saying you
make some pretty harsh charges against
the Obama administration in its dealings
with Iran about this Iranian deal about
what really is going on there but you've
been such a great guide for what's
happening on the other side the Sunni
side of the Islamic Revolution but now
you come in here and you're saying this
maybe even the greater enemy to question
to get ready to bat should we just not
let them fight each other right now let
them believe each other out I mean is
that is that is that a strategy for the
West and just kick back and let that and
let them have at it since the sense
they're bound and determined both to be
the supreme force in the Islamic world
is a real strategy for us now just a
step back let him get at it
I don't see why not Steve in 1980s Iran
and Iraq fought a war for eight years
now during a brutal world a war just
almost like world war one now that I put
not reported in Western media but it was
trench warfare yeah very much so and as
essentially stalemate and essentially no
how many how many casualties oh I don't
know actually but they were I'm sure
they were immense casualties because it
was very costly for both sides the
Islamic Republic almost fell Saddam
Hussein had his own troubles and the
thing is during that time neither one of
those were causing trouble for the West
so what's the downside we cannot prevent
Sunnis and Shia from hating each other
we only we need to recover Western
leaders need to recover a sense that
their primary responsibilities to
protect their own citizens and this is
this as I read this book and you do a
great job of going back through the
ancient history of it you also bring us
up currently you talk about you know
everything from from the surrender these
of those patrol boats in in in the
Persian Gulf to the Iran deal and
everything in between is this beyond
Islam because when you read your history
I mean is this not Athens and
versus Persia I mean is this not the
West versus the Persia is a they were
the last major Society in the Islamic
world really to fall to the Islamic
revolt what is it like in 1500 or
something like that was much longer than
than the Arab world well they were
conquered in the seventh century century
but but they didn't they became shiite
in the sixteen yeah but they have is are
they looking themselves first as
Persians or against the West in that
arrogance of kind of how the Persian
dynasties always look down their nose at
Rome and Athens of being kind of
barbarians and they were a much higher
culture or is this really imbued with
with Islam well it's both they've
reinforced each other there's no doubt
that the Persians had a tremendous a
great civilization long before Islam
long before they fell to Islam and that
was a culture and a civilization that
was always at odds with the West always
fighting the Roman Empire and so it's
really just a continuation of that
ancient conflict but Islam then
reinforces that by giving the idea that
there's has to live that Muslims have a
responsibility to wage war against
non-muslims and of course this is the
basis on which Khomeini built the
Islamic Revolution and has made the kept
aslam Iran on a war footing against the
u.s. ever since 1979 on Islamic
principles here's what you actually make
the case here that they are in the Islam
and the existential war we're fighting
against this radical Islam the thesis by
far the greater enemy am i taking that
no you're absolutely right that this is
by far the great enemy than the
Caliphate of Isis which is a man
butchering murderous cult writer aspect
of a fundamental Islam you're saying
which is the siege of Mecca and
everything came out of that you're
saying this is far deeper far more
serious and far more in our face yes
Iran is what Isis wants to be when it
grows up Iran has a global network of
terrorist organizations under its
control not only Shiite but also Sunni
Hamas Palestinian Islamic Jihad which is
also Sunni and those groups Hizballah
note most notably have a presence in the
West they are Hezbollah is working
actively in Mexico with the drug cartels
teaching them to behead teaching them
their tactics and that's all aimed at
getting into the United States
they already have sleeper cells in the
United States nine years ago there was
an FBI report that said there are
Hizballah sleeper cells in the United
States that's Iran essentially and that
they were waiting for a time to strike
but right now they were getting making
so much progress without striking that
they were gonna lay low because of
course they didn't want the police
attention that would come from the
strikes those cells are still in place
and there's nothing but more of them now
what here's the other thing and by the
way the book is called the complete
infidels guide to Iran it's out by reg
rate that authors Robert Spencer
probably the most renowned are among the
most renowned of folks that are on the
watchtower to make sure that we're fully
aware of this threat in this existential
war with the Frank Gaffney's of Pamela
Geller's he's head of jihad watch was it
which is a go-to site here's this
disturbing thing as you compile it in a
book and you get to sit down evening and
start to read it it's so in-your-face
this is what's stunning to me I've
sitting there going how this that
they're so out front by saying there are
mortal enemy they're going to destroy us
it's an everything they talk about they
don't try to hide it why do we seem as a
country in a nation incapable of
accepting that and addressing it well I
think that it's because in the first
place am I wrong in that that we just
don't take it as seriously okay as they
as they tell us that's central to them
every every week in the mosques they
chant death to America during the Friday
prayers it is central to them to hate
the United States and to consider
themselves to be at war with the United
States and Americans don't know this but
I think how can we not know this well it
hasn't been taken seriously
well why is it not taken seriously
because the Iranian military doesn't
have anything near the capability of
ours the idea that they would go to war
with us in an actual shooting war is
something that would just set them up
for destruction and so the the the
military in the political establishment
have not taken it seriously just the
intention does the other aspect that the
intelligence community and particularly
the forward-leaning in telling you take
it seriously no I don't think so and
also that has time how can this be this
is just because it's to their account
the Caliphate hopes to be a country
they're claiming they have land and
territory now to become the new
Caliphate from from the Ottoman Turks
but these guys have a major nation they
have an ancient civilization they have a
major capital in Tehran they have a they
have tremendous oil resources they have
all of that why why then is the
intelligence apparatus in the military
apparatus besides our politicians and
Borg apparatus why they not taking a
service I think that the Obama
administration has made a conscious
decision to empower Iran to be the
stabilizing force in the Middle East
well they clearly have done that but is
this deeper than just the Obama
administration yes
is it systemic inside the military and
those in the intelligence we that's why
we get to it's more than just you can't
change out a guy because it's different
it's there's something's past and that
why is that well I think they don't take
seriously the Islamic Republic's
ideological basis they don't take they
refuse to understand that Islam is not a
religion of peace that it is on a war
footing with non-muslims and so a whole
country that's based on that proposition
they they can't even see it they refuse
to acknowledge the existence of such a
possibility but unless there's a fifth
Khamenei this is what's so maddening you
document just page after page after page
that this is their official policy as a
country so they're not trying to hide it
it just begs that rationale people
cannot assume there's particularly
rational professionals in the
intelligence and the military yes well I
do think that we have embarked upon a
period of irrationality that the
essentially the political establishment
is insane insanity is okay yours ago
your your level had a guy that's why how
can we I mean how can we believe that
how you believe people are saying cuz I
know these guys these guys are smart
geysers
you're down in DC you're out Langley
you're at these other places you're over
the Pentagon you've had these yes I was
I was unable officer I went back to the
Pentagon you know and inside the the
e-ring they're rational people they're
rational actors the rational people get
hungry Stan how do you tell me that the
whole system is gone man based on a
false premise and it's not that they're
there they're crazy like they should be
locked up but that they refused to
accept the fundamental premise which is
that this is a religion that councils
war and that this is a state that is
based on the those religious teachings
they refuse to accept that look I'll
tell you 1979 when Khomeini took over
nobody in the state depart
and had read a single book that he had
written nobody knew anything about what
he was all about they just thought he
was a religious fanatic and that he has
gone to Paris had gone to Paris been
radicalized and came back it was only
last a couple years in execu nobody
understands or take seriously the depth
and the power of the Islamic ideology
whether Shiite or Sunni what not let's
let's pivot to why what possessed Obama
what geopolitical aspects or ideological
aspects had Obama in his administration
carry pivot to think that if you read
this book and see all the hate and
vitriol that the United States day in
and day out in their education system in
their media and all that in this thing
about moderates there are no moderates
and the moderate guys are the are the
are kind of crazy the hardcore are
really crazy right I shouldn't say crazy
they're very methodical and coming out
how could any rational person in the
world think that they would be a
moderating influence they are a state
they do have this great history and is
that what Kerry's thinking I was playing
to the Persian element of that versus
the Bedouin yeah I think so this is of
course they don't see Islam you know
they see no Islam here no Islam speak no
Islam so Islam has nothing to do with
Iran as far as they're concerned and
they figure Islam is Iran is a powerful
state that can is the only powerful
state left with Saddam gone in that
region and so if they are kind to it it
will be kind to us and bring stability
to that region they're basing their
print their principles on the way
Western people think and thinking we can
sit down and talk out our differences
and figure this all out the idea that
there's this implacable implacable
ideology that will never compromise and
never come to terms and be friends with
us they kept they refused to admit that
as a possibility they think we were way
beyond of that stage and in the world
some of the some of the you know else
eases some of the Sunni potential allies
and look we have a huge problem with the
royal family in Saudi Arabia of how they
how they sold us out however our
quote-unquote allies in in the Middle
East
how have they viewed what the Obama
administration has been doing in this
pivot to actually they're more mortal
enemy than they are to us well the
Saudis the as problematic as they are
are appalled by all this and they have
actually said some state made some
statements about that they'll just gonna
they're gonna have to get nukes if the
Iranians get nukes and that's
essentially the Americans giving the
Iranians the green light to get them
then they're going to proceed
accordingly and they gypped also and the
problem is is that what is true what was
intended to be a stabilizing force for
the Middle East is essentially going to
set the whole region even more on fire
than what is it get into the book or
walk people through what was the logic
of actually allowing and supposedly an
administration in a country that said
hey we don't want any more proliferation
of nuclear weapons what was the internal
logic of cutting the Iran deal that the
Iranians are going to get nukes anyway
and so if we legitimize the process then
they will look upon us more kindly and
return our kindness with kindness of
their own it's it's a it's another false
premise based on the idea that everybody
is essentially the same and that the
Iranian mullahs are going to have the
same kind of thought processes that
Western secular politicians do look at a
lot of the mainstream media could say
hey look this is Robert Spencer's guess
tinfoil hat on again he's got the rabbit
ears up however you could say that no
you could say that but then the New York
Times have Ben Rhodes walk us through
the Ben Rhodes thing and it still hasn't
created a media firestorm like it should
walk through what Ben Rhodes in the New
York Times is supposed to be a glowing
profile yeah but he happened to tell the
truth it's astonishing and I have it's
it's actually breathtaking is that he
lied they devised a strategy to lie to
the American people to claim that
rouhani the president of Iran was a
moderate which he is most decidedly not
and that they could reason with moderate
forces within the Iranian regime to come
to a nuclear accord that would bring
peace it was all a lie and Rhodes
admitted it right in the New York Times
and the adora in a minute that he worked
that the the internet community and
favorite reporters and put this message
out and they reinforce it and then other
and they mocked how little understanding
that the reporters had of this region it
could be sold as full of goods easily in
the air they were proud of it oh yeah
well you know they knew that there are
reporters that they will always do
anything they can to make the Obama
administration
look good and so they knew they could
count on them and they did okay but
here's what I don't understand that as
let's posit that that is a fact and
you've proven that in the book and you
walk through that you know the founders
set up a system of government to say hey
there's always gonna be those kind of
guys you have a checks and balance of
review
how did corker people that were supposed
to review this that are not on that side
of the football that are rational actors
how did it get passed everybody well
this is something that mystifies me that
the Republican establishment did not
challenge Obama on this and let it go
through and they've been lying down all
seven and a half years now and it's just
it's mystifying
but people wonder well how is it that
Donald Trump has gotten so popular well
that's why because we don't really have
an opposition in this country right now
and he represents the frustration of the
people in that regard do you think if
this was treated as a treaty do by the
way do you believe it's a treaty well no
doubt but no doubt in your mind
absolutely no doubt yes and the framers
would say hey you've got to come back
with two-thirds votes because that shows
has been debated and the American people
even get two thirds and Senators
basically you you've proven to the
American people that's something we
should do why did corker and these other
Republicans fall for this thing with
Obama how did that happen
I think that they also believe that
gesture Olive Branch hauled out to Iran
is going to bring peace and stability
and it's it's just fans or anybody is
any pattern of evidence in the history
of Persia or the history of Iran's has
become Islamic to show that I'm showing
them an olive branch has ever worked
never never no not one shred of evidence
not one bit it leads one to believe then
because I believe people are rational
and I believe people there is something
it's it's it's quite dark in this book
and you don't actually get to it is
there a fifth column in this country
because you just can't be this many
people who are rational who are doing
irrational things I'll tell you this the
one thing that is in the book is that
the Canadian Embassy a few years ago the
Iranian embassy in Canada was shut down
because it was found to be a center of
espionage for the Islamic Republic in
Canada and not only of espionage but of
terror plotting and so the Harper
government closed it down
now in that is related to your question
because is the same thing happening in
the Iranian embassy or in what the
Iranians used for diplomatic contacts in
the United States there's no doubt
whatsoever and would they infiltrate if
they had the chance and try to influence
policy there's no doubt whatsoever a big
part of this was the economic aspects of
this and people saying hey we don't do
this you're gonna get all these
contracts and stuff and the way you
moderate these people is get into
business with them and do this you know
throwing out the lessons of World War
one where global trade was all uniting
and guys still fought the bloodiest war
when the blights wars in history they
said hey we get more business
relationships and more contacts but do
you think the business community was
pushing this to happen because they
don't mind trading with the enemy yes I
don't have any doubt about that
whatsoever
and a pretty harsh charge it is it is
but back at US ambassador Boeing was
found to have been paying off lobbyists
to lobby for this deal so they could do
business with Iran and that came out
after the book was finished but it just
did it verifies talking about that
following things is pretty shocking the
amount of money they paid it for
consulted it was live billion
yeah if I've been was overall deal but
they pay for you some of the hundreds of
millions of dollars yes yes and so
people that's my point about a fifth
column are people looking the other way
because of economic interests that they
have in these sorts of relationships
with people that are the sworn
existential enemy of the United States
yes that's a documented fact there's no
doubt about that whatsoever